if I start screaming I'm gonna wait for
that you to tweet out while I'm going
let's wait for that babble oh it looks
like it received it pretty fast but I
still want to get my right and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
and the Lords of gaming dotnet episode
number 142 it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable on the
Lord's Day I'm very excited about our
special guests and we've got compulsion
games PS 5 skipping III Last of Us 2 and
a rising doing possibly the PC so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a lady whom the ILP is
extremely fortunate to have cross
password thanks to the due diligence of
our very own Lord addict now as I guess
were the most down-to-earth industry
figures in the game but she's also the
personification of a true gamer with the
passion of match introducing the PR and
community developer of compulsion games
captain Scarlett herself and arguably
the best cosplay version of older
watches Anna you will ever see in the
flesh laughs Montreal and making her
debut into the realm of the lords my
girl lady nyla Hodges of compulsion
games
how're you doing this you are welcome
you are a lord in your realm it's only
right we show you the proper respect
here at the round table
how's it doing good good very good
excited to be here and starting a new
year uh you know new new beginning new
beginnings new Begay so game wise I know
I know your big game have you got a
chance to play anything recently have
you been gaming recently all you just
been all big no no I I came on I always
keep time for gaming always lately I'm
trying to finish that's trending okay
which is uh which is
you know you have to grind a little bit
and you have to get you going
but um yeah Lourdes may be down Lord
addict was responsible for this of what
she may be very sick he was throwing up
so please if you see Laura go to send
him our regards a horseman is down but
of course we still have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single-player selfish
experience and also the sastra darkness
mr. off my profile Illuminati and lore
patron of the iron bank my man
Lord sovereign are you doing sir good
eat good evening a little tired look
great kind of a crazy week where you
know I was I was I was I had two screens
on I was watching boxing and you ever
fell to the wayside unfortunately I just
I needed to focus on UFC you know man
yeah what can I say like at least say do
you want to get right into the
particulars or should we should be way
as I just kick and I go on I'm not a fan
uh-uh
I love to see growth in there okay 30
seconds of actions was grown back to me
we girl know that shut up to Xavier
makan you guys are fire love you got Oh
Lucas slaughter your septic ghosts and
they love the Lord out again hopefully
we get them to cameo schools tank top in
there nice salute what a load up Chuck
we'll be back for long shock
oh my god so it what have you been plays
there's all baby anything you've been
playing this beak nothing this week was
kind of nuts I did it wasn't playing
again he's posing
I never uninstalled it though it's this
so what about cake at this point I mean
I should just volunteer to play no I
can't finish this with you because I
have yet to I started a way out with
King Oh probably probably two years ago
now I love this game so much we still in
jail right now no it's totally my fault
I deserve all the fraud this that I
guess mmm I was playing oh oh man I
don't even remember their names ago I
play a little control this morning maybe
two hours of control a man the side
story stuff in that is is kind of I like
the fact that it's just not it's best
quests and stuff like that is busy work
but it's all story oriented right so it
goes back to kind of giving that world a
kind of sense of really existing that's
what I love with my remedy games right
it's just the characters and the story
and every single every single ER game
that they make is a world unto itself
and they make sure that everything that
you find in that world ties back into
what the story they're trying to tell
you you're gonna kick yourself in the
butt so the game past because you were
boom actually I hit fine games I'm not
buying no more
I'm kind of kicking myself yeah it's two
minutes too many too many yeah I'm not
kicking myself I'm kicking myself a
little bit for plague tale because it's
a fantastic game I'm glad that I bet
I've got it
but just to see that it's coming I'm
excited that more people are gonna get
to play it and more people are gonna be
willing to put that time in because it's
fantastic
Rhys shoutout for the free course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
XS gamer who's back the lord of combat
sports kick of the statues who demands
nothing less to that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement cool
beloved Lord King how you doing sir oh
you know exactly how I'm doing boxing
out the way let's go j-rock versus a
Jameson Rosario banana my man banana
that's from the Dominican Republic when
I saw the on the lead-up to the fight
mm-hmm oh boy he's in the Dominican
Republic chillin with his legs that
relaxing his family is not too far away
but he was in the mountains and he was
training with his team and he comes from
absolute poverty I'm talking about
poverty his poverty was so stricken his
cell phone that he was talking to on his
arm with his daughter the screen was
crack him stick me with you know with
the finger you know yeah but you know
the tape will you figured he needed you
know cut your fingers video he's
facetiming with his daughter and I fell
for him I felt his story I felt that
j-rock will lose this fight shoutout to
the new champion James him a banana
Rosario oh I love it
he won the championship the only way he
could be j-rock is you have to punch
when he's punching you have to in
between shots and he fantastically did
that and just like the cholo brother did
when he caught him with the uppercut and
knocked him out that upper cut his J
ROCs weak spot he doesn't know how to
grab I mean he knows how to throw a good
punch but he doesn't know how to
when he's hurt and so you have to go
back to the drawing board and just keep
throwing punches and try to grab when
you get hurt but let's go over to UFC
Gregor has made his triumphant return
cowboy was served up on a platter and
how you do or pigeon how you do a pigeon
wings when a new shoulder move
you hit him like four times we're like I
was surprised know what he was doing
there's no way cowboy could know what
was going on and hold on one sec shout
that gay before Taylor the $2.00 super
Chad thank you brother breasts to be in
the house of the Lois hashtag go Titans
you still got a couple more hours the
football stay without stay with shows
listener so so why he's different right
he was he's peppering them up the whole
time and it was vintage Conor this kind
of looks so fresh I don't know what they
preserved this man with but he looks so
fantastic and this is what I got to say
you got to show excellence whenever
you're doing your craft young man was in
his bank know through the shoulder up
and it not calm or cut boys like he just
hit me with it was no way he could punch
me that close and cowboy was off his
beam and off his being his squabble was
speaking a fight to combat talk so last
night
Conor McGregor took a huge step
solidifying himself as the UFC's ungodly
champion that BMF belt look like isn't
danger now Marc Dolph if he catches you
with those shots to the body to the head
and your D Nima's off you're finished
son
a bigger guy and a monster doors like I
don't think Marva Demasi
he's not standing with Connor he's gonna
try to take him down and yoke him out
I think though his ego may make him
stand though anti wrestler mentality so
all shout out to yellow has led to my
first time seeing a shoulder shot
amazing yeah it was it was crap I will
say this you know I just real quickly
because I know we got a lot of gaming to
talk about how to move this song but um
no the thing I would say is shout out to
Connor I was very worried for him to be
honest you know saying the long layoff
you know he had the big payday with
Floyd you know he lost it and could be
with guys like that you know you wonder
if they get paid they get that I mean
he's set for life for the most part if
he didn't explain his splurge it so you
wonder what guys mentally if he's still
gonna have that dedication when he did
that move that showed me he's still
working on his craft he's doing things
I've never seen before so salute to him
you know sky's the limit as far as well
he has so many options you can do the
BMF belt for the big payday with Mazda
dog I'm on got booze mom for the title
he got run bump he's in a good spot so
I'm here [ __ ] okay Pat Cass and I'm work
no no they're looking at Pacquiao but
what's more on traveling or tables
deployed Oh or to be coming back this
year anyway what I was playing this this
week um shout out the game pass we go it
has validated my whole opinion or how I
feel my philosophies a lot about
philosophies today people and my Lassa
fees on game pass it is it is the best
value on any platform to date I mean if
it blows out
streaming services like Netflix to stuff
like that in things me plus it's on our
level of in credibility like my son gets
a chance to play all these games but
Tech and drop check and seven dropping
and my boy that has game pass hit
me up and you do you want smoke the
second smoke us a hotel is he talking to
you just challenge the boss like
challenges all first I said okay the
fact that you're gonna knock on my
doormat the beat you back the first the
first thing it just made me take some
weirdo do and so it's so many new
different characters in this game and
I'm this is this is the format for
getting past for all those people out
there yelling out the developer doesn't
get any money doesn't hear a person when
I purchased the game I noticed that I
didn't have I was cut off from a lot of
crew shoot DLC right so if I purchase
DLC for game and I don't have the core
game right I purchase all the DLC house
I get that was $50 right there boom so
already they got engagement from me then
they got the $50 from me
now don't you think when this game is
getting ready to leave game pass if I
don't own a core game and I just brought
a ton of DLC I'm gonna have to buy this
game at the 10% discount game past gives
you okay game is sold to me I brought
all the DLC on a game that was probably
like two or three years old extending
the life of the game bring it and bring
a little more engagement to it at that
point
win-win so listen shout out the game
pass I'm looking forward to getting
control in every other game that I can
get my hands on that I would not
otherwise purchase on my own so this
opens the door for a lot of gamers this
opens the door for a lot of new
experiences and if you're afraid of new
experiences and new free games Malena
free you're spending $10 a month but if
you enough for that three dollar deal
boy you're having a great run oh yeah
shout out shout the game pad definite
one of the best values in gaming su l
boogie and a chat was going on see them
Oh shall we mr. turtle should die with
the file a super chat thank you brother
shoutout to the panel from
your compatriot always with the best
concert thank you so much 103 in the
chat live please hit that like button
out too okay kids move in the final
super chat need to know compulsives next
project will they be at e3 or PAX East
week we will get almost there we almost
done with the intro video shout to Titan
2793 what did that $1 super chat with
the 100 sign on us much appreciated
so yeah King I'm feeling what she going
through her stuff like that and of
course we you know we got me the gaming
ninja the shinobi Lord kognito spreading
every honest it around my LP not telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear so for me it has been done
heinous five is completed I'm sitting in
the lurch absolute attic salute the
Kaiba - they got it done you know I
won't go into too deep but um definitely
definitely liked the ride solid solid
game some brutal choices at the end for
those who haven't play I'm not gonna
spoil but um Wow they make you make a
tough decision
my other question which said decision is
will they do a Mass Effect and I'll
situation where the save data of the
choice
goes into the next game so if it's
candidate which it haven't said which
today I would say which is I want to
know if if coalition makes that cannon
choice already it is a in the next game
or is it a situation when you boot up
gears what is it six you boot up gear
six and it's like hey if you did this
then you know this is like it's custom
because the fact that you take your
whole library with you obviously we
talked about the fights and all that
other stuff destiny non-stop Soham
special dump it now last thing we'll
talk about is our pls realm send your
thoughts your prayers and support to
Lord Italian clowns man on him and his
wife Lady Ashley she was in a horrific
car accident the car was completely
totaled
she's very fortunate to be with us
I saw the pictures of a latest update
from clowns was unfortunately she's back
in the ER with a t3 spinal fracture and
a right rib she's still scheduled for
neurosurgery neurosurgery and I just
want to give real quick last year if you
would help the family I'm gonna put
something in there right now um please
it actually show us some of the graphic
image of the accident it's it's a
blessing she still with us you know I
got a chance that Guardian calling to
meet them in Orlando and I'm very cool
actually I was the one that showed them
their first UFC fight um and I think
like we're like a buffalo why when
they've never seen UFC she was awesome
so I've met her personally
clowns you already know his friends to
the realm for guys with quarter podcast
please send your love send your prayers
if you can help I put the GoFundMe link
in the chat the community is definitely
coming together this is a good dude man
I'm telling you I speak to him a lot and
all I told I said bro it's like that
she's still with us because the accident
was pretty horrific so had to do that
for the wrong for my brother heal up
lady Ashley so switch the energy a
little bit more positive
um yes oh well now that we've gotten
that and get what the games everybody's
been playing I want to start with lady
lady nyla a video game system history
her journey into the game it really
agree Mia to actually coming to PR and
community developer at the up incoming
compulsion games one of the most recent
addition to Xbox game studios so Wow
let's stop for the beginning what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what kind of got you into gaming
well I have two older brothers so when
someone I was young they already had
like her I mean Tendo so that's how he's
you know with Mario under Nintendo very
okay yeah and then I think from the
moment I just saw them play and started
playing with them it I fell in love
right away so then Tendo and then you
know I think having two older brothers
around really fostered me we were all
three of us play games all of our lives
and then every time I a system would
come up we would just jump on it every
Nintendo Super Nintendo GameCube
PlayStation off of all of them you
you had some good breath brothers at the
Tanis kind of dictates showing you was
going okay you know like beating me up
at Street Fighter become you know way
better than them no but it was fun
because you you wanna games would like
Resident Evil when they would come out
they would they would play them and I
would be so scared but at least I would
still be behind enjoying them even
though like they would be controlling I
could still experience them nice even it
was very scary so you were really
indoctrinated you all part of that yeah
now I was gonna say is obviously a lot
of intend to love now of course I'm a
little biased I was a Sega kid growing
up so I gotta ask
did they ever by any Sega systems know
Genesis no Dreamcast
she said no not necessarily because they
didn't want to I think it was I think
back in the days you know parents they
let's say dig by your system they think
oh a Nintendo and they call everything a
ninja so they don't think I'm gonna buy
them a Sega for them it was very foreign
it wasn't even it was like oh yeah
that's the thing the kids want yes I
think yeah that's a fantastic play
because it's funny from a parent
perspective back then they don't know
all the consoles right no everything you
said everything has the Nintendo
connotation because I know what about as
far as systems now obviously came up
under your brothers you guys all game
together now it was at every point where
you purchased like your first system or
your own like separate or later on or
you guys stay together that well I got
it I think the less system they bought
was the the Gamecube and then and a ps2
and then I bought my first ps3 oh yeah
so well no but it was a generation I
started buying and then right now
they're they're older and they have kids
and stuff so they don't a man and now I
buy them
because I feel like you know they took
such a good care of me when I was young
and buying me those systems because they
were way older and they could they had
money and now they too busy and I'm like
okay well I'm an adult and now I can pay
you back
that's a tremendous now again you say
yeah he's brought the system down and
obviously they know what she do so
that's pretty much so let's get into
that now as far as like the whole your
whole career as far as getting started
in the industry and stuff like that you
know and then obviously joining
compulsion as the PR and community
developer like we know you've got I know
you got a lot of QA experience and stuff
like that so like how did you get into
and break into the industry so I moved
back to Montreal when I was 18 and I was
going to school and at the same time I
needed a side job and my mom found this
ad on the paper for a QA tester and
she's like do you like video games why
don't you do this I'm like okay so I
went in and I you know when you're 18
and you're like oh this is a dream job
you know video game and I loved it so
much and and all the people all the
others were all my age it was it was
really nice that I I stopped going to
school
you know I'm 18 I can do I can I can
make my own decisions now this is great
I'm getting paid to do so I stopped
going to school and I could tell you
they just continued working in there and
working my way up basically nice so I
knew the I knew the video games industry
was where I wanted to be so I was like
okay I have a foot in know I just need
your hustle in mmm God awesome so you
looked ahead out but - that's awesome
cuz you took advantage the opportunity
you stopped out for now a lot of people
don't realize - I tested is that easy
like oh yeah like cuz these it a lot of
to it right yeah and you don't
necessarily play great games either like
I was on Peppa Pig on the ds3 months you
know
it's not always glamorous and I'm
assuming you don't you don't necessarily
have the are you actually are you
actually playing through the game or
they they give you like a specific
section and say hey run around the
collection and see if something's broken
it depends pick up it was a very small
game so you could go through it very
easy usually if it's a huge game like at
the time we had for example I worked on
the Force Unleashed back in the days
like a Star Wars game and is a bigger
game so we would have like sections each
had a level that we would we have to
play over and over and break but ya know
you have to play the whole you do
several anyway you're like months on the
same game and you can drink in that zone
so like the first few times you finish
it as any player would if you can and
then you you know you grind and and
touch and try to all the buttons in
every aspect of the level and yeah so
yeah it's not bad clever it's really
actually but it's fun it's you have to
you have to go through them you have to
go through the Monday before you know me
so now you work your way through and do
a QA like what's the name like what
what's the next big goal for you that
that you hit correct yes
so then I then you still has a tester
and then became like a manager I just
seen company and then I left for a
little while I wanted to try something
else so I I work other odd jobs and then
I was like you know what I really miss
being back in video games so then I went
back into it and I went to THQ Montreal
they open an office back in the days
yeah yeah and orth on you would see a
little bit so mmm because I know nothing
but UFC so but it was still hard to do
manager there and and then they closed
but that maybe open just Eastern or day
and then I worked for a small not small
but like a mobile game company in
Montreal company yeah okay that was fun
it was okay but it's like mobile game
which isn't a silly what I wanted to do
mm-hmm and then one Charlotte because
there's so many Jude studios in maturity
there's a lot of events for for
developers so this you see the same
people it's a very small community
gotcha
so you know I was on one of those events
and you meet people you know you network
and everything and that's where I met
the founder of compulsion games were
outside yes yes the legendary key oh
okay we were outside having a smoke and
he was with at the time he was battling
dizzily which is the creative director
of my senses created and I had worked
with and I teach you again material is
very small so then he's like oh hey this
is my friend glioma he made contrast and
I love to contrast oh yeah it was
beautiful idea for I was one of the
launch titles are very well liked this
is my friend um and I said oh my and I
ain't know and I can girl let's go yeah
and then Hume had heard that I wanted to
switch from Q way to community mm-hm
let's we all have again small community
friends in common Alissa so they sent me
an email and it said hey we hear you're
looking to make the switch from Kuwait
to community we're a small studio there
was not that many people and you know we
know you don't let me tell you have a
lot of experience in it but we are small
so we can take a chance on each other
you know what I'm like absolutely no I
was so happy to just switch I just I
just wanted to be with people who were
creating games that were like touching
and beautiful and out of the norm you
know absolutely and then and then I
joined them and we were I went from a
company alluvium we were like 500 people
and it were like 10 people in a very
small room
Wow very humble beginnings during that
age wow that's a transition but it just
shows you show you like you said like
you know you being diligent you staying
around in the industry
and wanted to kind of still expand your
role in your skillset and to this
opportunity provide itself with one of
your favorite games you know like that's
pretty cool that's pretty cool the
question I had now is not you've been
there um you know like what's it like to
be like the face of the coming line
you're basically the person the go-to
person you handle everything the
convention stuff like that like how does
that transition in this role feel well
uh you mean how it started how you
started that's like how does it feel to
be a fit like your face that could
accompany it away I mean I don't find I
mean I feel like I answer a lot of
people but they don't necessarily know
me they just oh the automatic you know
yeah it's it's nice it's I think I like
I like talking to people I'm a very
social person and I think I'm a gamer
first before being second so when people
come to me with problems I you know it's
I think as if I would reach out to a
company I would want to be treated you
know mm-hmm so I just I mean it's it's
it's great it's fun and it's just look
you got the passion it shows that what
you do and I think it's key for your own
especially you know community developers
are they interacting with you what's
your base and stuff like that because
obviously there's both these two sides
to it you know you see the negative side
and I want and why isn't this complain
complain complain and I said you've got
to deal with both sides of it but that's
pretty cool that's cool earned a lot
because we at some point we had a lot of
we had a big backlash basically and we
had a lot of people you know yelling at
us and and what you learned from this is
that people really don't necessarily
some people [ __ ] because I really want
a [ __ ] but some others are just it's
how they express themselves and they
don't necessarily have the they don't
have the words for it and maybe reach
out in anger and I think with this I
learned that when you answer them in a
nice positive way and say hey I I
understand what you're frustrated about
and I'm here to help you don't worry
about it we can figure it out together
they can
really taken by like oh my god you
actually care my god force I care you
know it's we and then they change the
tone right away they start angry and
nice but it's because they just little
empathy for everyone goes very important
community developers take note now you
drop acknowledged right now so on let's
get to the main event and um you know
the reason why we hit obviously it's
it's compulsion games right and as a
studio and you know I remember like you
said contrast initially when it came out
it was just very unique title with the
puzzle elements the shadows stuff like
that for ps4 and then obviously then you
guys transition till we happy few
it had that major debut you know saying
III 2016 stage I remember you know it
winning xbox preview recently you know
that all the DLC down was out I believe
what if we all fall down was the last
one yeah right and at least a few months
back so I just want to talk about
compulsion as a studio like what's the
atmosphere at compulsion and then like
what do you think makes you guys unique
from the other xbox game studios Oh
interesting but the atmosphere is we
very much kits are indeed attitude so
it's married if you come into the office
it's a little bit messy it's uh
sometimes we have people focus on
visiting and they say yeah okay let's
talk about it's a tour of the studio
we're like oh not embarrassed but you
know it feels like we're all roommates
living each other so we still got there
like college dorm and be Bob okay
solutely wrap with the to Allison for
chat salute Lords great guest today PC
master-race salute salute to y'all right
now to continue and so this is the end
is very chill and you know we like we
like to on fridays we'd like to have
some beers that work play some games go
out very tight yes that's what so that's
awesome that's awesome Oh
you gotta jump because I got a bunch of
questions I'll be on my bag so okay okay
I mean I guess I guess my one of the
questions that I have when you go from
contrast to to on we happy for you like
when I first saw we happy few for me it
was like wow oh hold on you immediately
to get bio-clock vibes right and I'm a
huge immersive sim fan so when I got
into the world of we happy for you I
said okay I I got those vibes right and
I also got like obviously the survival
vibes and stuff like that do you guys
see yourselves as as a studio that's
kind of gonna continue along that path
or do you see yourselves kind of
expanding into different activity not
maybe gameplay but it may be or may be
diving even deeper into into the
immersive sim yeah the reason we wanted
to just simulate him with a survival
game with we happy fuse because we were
not many people in the studio were like
10
so making a roblox revival for us was
the easiest way to make a game that you
know it doesn't have to be very big it
just has it just needs a lot of ability
so and then as the game it grabs so much
attention and people looked at us and
said oh by a shovel and they're like but
we don't want to survival we want an
action adventure just like so be
modified it to be to be is to be an
actual like full-on action adventure it
used a lot from the mission I leave you
to the actual conception and finish of
the product yeah I don't know maybe but
I think we have a little bit of PTSD so
crazy I think try something different
maybe for now but I think even more than
the survival aspect like when you put
that entire story together that is an
amazing story
yeah you guys are really amazing
storytellers I get really yeah so I mean
whatever you guys do the fact that I'm a
story buff so
all characters and story and I think you
guys have that nail so it's just a
matter where you take gameplay next yeah
exactly is where we need to shine in the
future I think we I think we're good
art our direction art Whitney or
directories amazing and and our writers
are so passionate and they write great
stuff they make me laugh every day and
then wanted writing you know they saw
they write constantly like 24/7 if they
don't write they feel very anxious
they're like dad pressure writing and so
I think game play as we slowly be happy
for you know it changed so much and we
had a lot of trouble nailing down the
gameplay aspect that's where so I think
that's what we learned from we have
issue we know whether strengths are and
we know what our weaknesses and we need
to do we need to invest in that bathroom
now to gave up my choice with the file a
super chat great show and the guest is
awesome she seems like an awesome person
and gamer looking forward to their next
game got some fancy an island those at
Lord acre man I see you have entered the
room is your mic sorry
oh we're just talking about obviously
you know the whole journey of compulsion
and obviously with contrast yeah a few
and then I'm just gonna get into know if
you had any questions in reference to
those two games before I go into my next
question is good keep those in devolve
storytellers stuff like that
bleh now I want to talk about one of the
our concern another a magic moment for
you guys and that was um II through 2018
and to me you get the call from you get
the car to be part of that all-star team
of Studios we affectionately call him
Phil Dominus Spencer here you sir do not
take you pyramid
20:18 compulsion games was officially
added to xbox game studios your name
came on that list of all-star team so I
want to get to the morale and energy of
the studio at that time because
obviously being you've talked offline
you know compulsion has had an
interesting journey right you mean from
the beginnings of contrast you know very
small and then you get gearbox kind of
to jump in and partner in with what he
we happy few and and then here comes
Michael like this doesn't happen to the
loudest a lot of studios if they don't
make a good game or necessary knock it
out the part the first time they're not
necessarily awarded all these chances
where people like no we believe in you
guys so give us the morale give us the
feeling Xbox games through your
announcement compunction games I'll take
you back a few months before is gone
three that's when when I was traveling
with Liam the founder we were going to a
press event to promote we happy few and
he tells me in the plane he's like you
know um Microsoft called us and they
want to buy us well then I don't when
the oh that's cool okay he's like no I'm
gonna do it and I went what what I guess
I didn't know what the thing you know I
had all these oh and we don't want to be
told what to do anything it's like no no
it's a good thing no it's like it's
gonna be good for the company and this
and that and then I started thinking of
all these positive things and how they
like they want to keep us how we are
they like can you repeat that can you
repeat that Center that is a big point
of contention with Microsoft studio
acquisition what directors ourself say
that they would allow you to do to keep
our life beautiful yeah the beautiful
the most beautiful part about it is they
came in with the bag and he said you
know listen amber just gonna give y'all
heads out of Microsoft is looking to
purchase us and then he was like oh okay
cool so what do you think I don't know
we again
within the bag is tremendous we are in
as a community face and the fears that
the company will have you took that on
and use like you know the first and
foremost but you know we're indie and we
don't like to be told what to do all
they're gonna mess what I want mine and
once he assured unit no man they gave
the money it was like do us um listen
I'm tired of other people trying to say
that Microsoft comes in and controls a
company right and the fact that you know
you can set up an attest to the fact
that yeah they dropped the bag and we
are in and our vibe is still the same
that's amazing to hear it's amazing it's
a dream come true honestly for like an
industry Oh to be able to keep creating
and having the tools because the problem
as India is that yes you can do whatever
you want but you funds are so hard to
come by you have to go you have to find
partners and shareholders and all these
things and now we don't have to worry
about this or worry if do we have the
money to hire programmer and things like
this you know so now that we you know
it's like here here's here's support do
what you do best that's it that is so
awesome
I definitely I know I know I'm
overstating but I'm glad you're
repeating that because again again like
we talked about most any students you're
not afforded that you know and it's
something to be said to still maintain
your creative control right the games
you want to create but also not worry
about the financial aspect so you kind
of breathe a little bit right right to
that point there was a lot of pressure
even with us we happy few didn't you
initially have like a Kickstarter and
goggles and stuff like that so the
finance you aspect of not having to
worry about and then having full
creative control and doing your vision
is really important at that's also
Guillaume was on board he he's like he's
doing you told you yeah yeah and I'm
like and Jim has been in video games for
like over 20 years and he's like I'm you
know I'm just like I'm tired and this is
great this is the best scenario that
could ever happen and I'm like you know
what it's your company you do whatever
you want them
before you it's it's gonna be great it's
gonna be if we get to keep doing what we
do it's just better so I mean why not
that's awesome you know it is awesome so
how the Titan 793 with the super chat
the big smiley face and money bags
that's funny Oh sad the boom in the
chance to lose everybody home
so yeah in reference to that with the
creative process again I want to double
down as far as um another thing I
constantly see what a lot of the new
Xbox games to do acquisitions is this
collaborative thing other studios so can
you like do you get to see it like maybe
either from a tech standpoint a creative
ideas or maybe like rare Ninja Theory
like are you guys working in
collaboration with these guys as well
yeah it's fantastic for example our
audio sound designer you know he has he
can he can talk to anybody and any
microsoft studio and you know have some
of their sounds for example or they have
a lot of conference where every
department every audio what is community
or programming animation they will all
get together and talk about processes
and techniques and everything so it's
definitely open a whole world of
knowledge and sharing that yeah so a lot
of the other companies that within the
larger company get a chance to share
tech and to share our abilities that you
may learn so one company might learn how
to get textures emotion cap up a lot of
a lot quicker whereas if you're looking
for that technology you're able to lean
on those other companies within the same
company to use the technology back and
forth so you're sharing knowledge within
each other yeah absolutely I I know our
programmers just came back well a while
ago from a conference and they learned
so much from legacy of these guys and
they're like oh my god they do it this
way and it's just a great way to do it
and knowing this make sure y'all get
that water these is no rare is knocking
it out the park
that is also sabe because I gots a
couple more questions to solve
I'll let me think I'm thinking about
interrupt me because I will go crazy
right now I love it all his nightly talk
right now so this is awesome so um yeah
about that obviously we got that um you
know in reference to you know we happy
few and you know obviously the dlcs have
come and gone we've got it we fair to
say you know I'm saying like the the
reviews are mixed but at this we do know
that that was developed before Microsoft
came before they can't drop the bag and
stuff like that so currently right now
as you stand like what's the like the
size of compulsion and the question
other question is it like multiple teams
or for the most part it's like one team
because you got a smaller and you
working on one project cuz I know Ninja
Theory has like two or three teams
that's about yeah we are currently 50
people okay and and we're looking to
expand yeah a bit more okay we're but we
still want it we don't we don't we don't
ago huge we want to stay okay so let
relatively small say that your next
project it may be more ambitious than
then we happy for you different okay but
yes for different reasons yeah okay shut
up to the except it goes he said nalli
did your studio philosophy change with
the resources that Microsoft bought you
guys know okay so flash magazine shout
lame so eighty six ten dollar super
chance salute awesome show awesome guest
getting some firsthand insight yeah
she's awesome compulsions awesome so on
and obviously you know I want to talk
about you know we have to talk about the
future you know I just on it and and
what I was hearing is that the game is
different from the past game got a
little something cooking baby
yeah visa look you know at the end of
the day I just wanted to give some kudos
because um I think even Aaron Greenberg
recently tweeted coming from you guys
you know studio and you know clearly
there were some pictures of some things
you were looking at once you got the
coffee there were some things that
people are excited about that clearly it
seemed to be a new project you know
obviously you made the statement
yourself that you know we happy few is
done you know as far as that was the
last dlc and the last thing i want to
talk about in reference to that it's
phil spencer himself he was on major
Nelson's end-of-the-year podcast and he
specifically said the studio everyone
should not sleep on is compulsion games
so we know something's cooking now I
know you can't spoil you're gonna get
you in trouble but at the end of the day
you know how excited should fans be for
the next project you know she's like not
not today
listen drama I'm trying
well how excited it's honestly of all
the games I've ever worked on it's
probably my favorite thing I've ever
heard whoa like the pit pitch and
everything is just awesome I don't know
I I know it looks beautiful and yeah one
thing that is public it's third person
more I hope table he said what kind of
genre
she gave us third person that delicious
there's something is something okay we
are excited well okay I can hear you up
okay I just wanted to ask um so what
what has been the consensus about
working with the series X what do you
mean in terms of in terms of how you
guys feel about it in terms of the
resources you're afforded as opposed to
working on the one like things like that
like a how much easier are better is it
to work on than what you've been used to
working on people saying like somebody
you know wow this is fantastic oh wow
this is so much easier the situation but
we do know is they do have a game
cooking and she said it's amazing and
she's a gamer so as of a game I'm gonna
tell you it's amazing and his third
person look out for me like I said
before like with with we happy few I saw
I saw like masterful storytelling like
really especially when you with all the
DLCs that's high the entire overarching
story of the of the game together in
such a way um I was like wow these guys
can really put a story together and when
you have that right when you have that
it's just a matter of just expanding the
other stuff out um so for me like I said
like I'm most excited for Studios like
like like you guys and like in exile and
stuff like that because these are
students that have been traditionally
been storytellers but just on a smaller
scale right but the fact that you have
these added resources and now you can if
you want to go bigger the opportunity is
there right so there's nothing holding
you back and like I said for me anytime
you give a studio with that sort of
pedigree more resources the stuff that
comes out of it but for me like in a lot
of ways the immersive sim is to me like
the ultimate game right it allows you
knows you in a world and allows you to
do whatever you would it allows you to
do manipulate the world in a way that
you couldn't in other games right but a
lot of that has to do with the
storytelling too so it's not necessarily
just just a gameplay thing but I'm just
excited what are we telling is a big
thing for us we don't want to we don't
want to tell stories that are you know
conventional yeah out of the norm
it's just otherwise it's boring yes I
love the fact when opted not to take the
pill the world started to crumble you
started to see the world for truly how
it was like what the hell is going on
here and the level of intrigue built to
a boil it was it was a slow simmer to a
boil and as you unlaid you know the
story just kept going further and
further and the fact that you know what
they were doing like with that with the
birthday party it was amazing to me how
it broke down those pills was definitely
of Matthew from the world it would it
felt like it felt that like that moment
when you like when you get unplugged
from the matrix wait and this is this is
way too real right you stop it and you
know that if at the start of the game
you take the pill game's over right the
games the game ends yeah it could be has
basically you've used to come to the
joys it's funny that you said that about
that the whole thing with the pillow
stuff cuz I heard a story I thought you
you were doing your community committee
develop a dig and you had tea paid and
he was asking about what is this game
about and you like yeah that was at e3
2016 when we first showed the instrument
like the birthday in the pinata yes and
then so we after the show on the e3 show
floor we had a demo of the game and then
so I'm there you know man in the booth
showing people
they came and then at some point
sometimes at these events you have yes
celebrities coming because they wanna
play game and then I had this person
coming TP wants to play your game I'm
like oh my god okay a few seconds later
I'm like surrounded by like two
bodyguards nice to meet you and okay so
this is our game and I explained to him
that the you know the basis of it and
I'm like basically you take drugs like
to say you live in a society when you
take drugs to stay happy so then she
completed the intro and I felt really
bad because again sometimes things
happen to gain crushes because he played
the intro then the game crashed and I'm
like oh I'm so sorry
you know it's like it's okay it happens
and I think chipping is a huge gamer so
he understands these kind of things so
so he didn't stick around to try again
because I mean the play of the game so
he was very gracious about it he's like
it's okay don't worry about it I'm like
no I'll send you a code if you want to
play it's gonna try he's like oh yeah
laughs will you told it last question
for the check because I don't check they
try to get too much inside information
is I don't we're not allowed to ask but
one question that was asked about I
didn't get a chance to ask you was about
game paths and um you know right now you
know a lot of gamers some some gamers
are struggling to understand this
concept right you know a game Xbox game
studios their games go into game pass
you know available day and date and
stuff like that and we've had other
developers or shout out to LA to 10
studios who we've had on and other
developers on dead labs we've had on and
we want to talk about the importance of
game paths because some people have a
misconception that you know if you put
the game in game pass you're not
supporting the developer you're not
gonna buy it because it's in game I'm
gonna give it the retail money so could
you were
explain like how you feel like game pass
helps compulsion games if at all you
know in reference this whole the whole
process is good um honestly I wouldn't I
wouldn't know because for we happy few
we it was still published by you right I
don't we don't have necessarily a
full-on experience with a brand-new game
that we do we do it for them for game
pass no question but I'm moving for but
I don't know I'm I guess it's honestly
it's a bit more it's a bit more let's
legal thing but it's just it seems like
it's I'm sure I mean game pass belongs
to Microsoft we belong to Microsoft so
if we put argument game pass you know
you're supporting us you're supporting
just by having game pass you're
supporting us fair enough unless Victor
Alice team toss-up check are you guys
closer to Double Fine in game design I
guess do you work with this question and
no we don't but I'm sure maybe we make
like similar colorful games yeah what he
means like what type of games that you
make I think that's what it means
Oh a lot of questions on limited time so
we gotta ask the final question that we
asked all the guests in the realm good
to know late I love your top 5 video
games or franchises of all time no
pressure
ok Legend of Zelda sure which one my
favorite one is it it's a tie but you
don't carry enough time I met Rose mask
okay I like them I mean Ocarina time was
amazing but Madras must was so dark and
twisted I loved it nice salute none of
the GameCube titles so the Last of Us
um Secret of Mana will always have a
special personal effect on you as a game
it may not you know just it may have
impacted you it had a tremendous
influence on you yeah you know what I
really like crunch rigor but that's
that's new he plated like last year for
the first time I was very late to it and
my friends for 10 years I've been
badgering me you know we have to play
and then I'm like okay and oh my god I
was amazing so I saw your resume with
retweet I saw yeah I'm playing him right
now because uh mr. boomstick he
definitely put to stick on me pose and
he's like he'll he got to play this game
and I purchased it and I'm really loving
this game I mean all these remakes are
it's true come true for great for a
gamer right and remain in such a
beautiful way dude - Alice LeBeau he's
like gonna go crazy for your joy I think
she's the first person to mention Chrono
Trigger in the top five I did okay and
then um but I think she's the first with
Secret of Mana Secret of Mana yeah that
and that's a classic she's like the only
one I
resident evil always gets love of course
Zelda always gets love to the RPG head
so cheese well that goes with the
cosplay I would have thought you
wouldn't a pig Zelda because of the
little kid that beat you out on the
stage like everything was a no-go you
look like yous definitely the winner be
honest with me and see the look kid but
I thought you know that no final
question Oh obviously you are known in
the realm well some of us know you as
well amazing cosplay will you ever bring
cosplay back very good you like a dead
ringer for over watches Anna like yeah I
can say yes if the firm went promoting
our next game okay you heard it here
first
so look absolute pleasure I know you got
a girl over yet for the first hour but
we had this Russian lady
nyla from compulsion game stop it by the
road dropping not true gamer tons of
passion dealing with our NBA breaking
questions dealing resident row lay down
awakened to find people find you and
what do you have going on on Twitter it
kept out Twitter and then that's a time
not very Mia
I'm not still growing social because my
job requests meet you today I keep about
mm-hmm Twitter okay cap this guy and at
compulsion games for those who don't
know right they need to follow that yeah
you if
if you tweet a compulsion or email or
anything even call us I will be
answering for sure I'll be the one
behind once once things start coming out
I'll be happy to come back and as things
get bounced in things that we can talk
about today we definitely will it would
be an honor to have you back in the room
that would be great I would love that
awesome thank you so much you have a
good day lady nyla thank you guys
composer games salute you salut yo wake
up for the love chat we gonna continue
all to show you were the only night I
may have to go um let's get into the
poll results last week poll results are
in and the people have spoken to the
question with the recent announcement by
Matt booty regarding the Xbox Series X
having no exclusive games at launch do
you agree with the cross-gen strategy by
Microsoft to start a new generation the
winner of the divisive three-way i/o
people at 58% is the yes series X Games
will still be the superior version
cross-gen is Pro consumer group coming
in at second at 37% was no Microsoft
needs to showcase the full power of
series X and not be held back by old
hardware and coming in at a very distant
3% of the vote I don't care power switch
Pro negates anything series X will
release in 2020 shout out to all the
lords who participated in last week's
Pro Lord sovereign I don't know it seems
like that poll question is a little
broken now yeah you know it's
considering certain information that's
coming down the pipeline
I think everybody's following Microsoft
- out the Titan 2783 tell us what you
had left
last question left or right Twix you're
absolutely table via silly
Oh shots now though the realm of the
stream team I in Lord you already know
and round table with the street team
host supper I'm just saying hello
pulling an attic playing while lurk I
would say to make him look as it's so
funny but I'm a coma I was running and
you want to get brats off with the last
rapid the two dollars super chat PC
master-race to always be the best
version of we're gonna get into it thank
you for your comments a professional
interview thank you thank you
so we go get into it obviously you know
there's a lot of Sony news I'm gonna
switch up the format because egging me I
think I think he knows what I'm talking
about
we've actually got some breaking news
already knows man fools - and again you
know the robot came out initially so
people would say take it from an assault
however it is brought to our attention
that there is a job description right
now a noisy dog for game graphics
program excuse me with the game - with
job description requirements join our
talented rendering team developed
implement new and exciting techniques to
our up in game last of us part two in
looking at the skill set through
thorough understanding of current GPU
architectures AMD which we obviously
knows in the PS 5 then it says GCN
obviously older technology nvidia
which is interesting in CUDA and then
the final bullet one of the
second-to-last bullets that really has
everyone kind of buckshot well yeah it
requires console and PC
programming experience I got a PC
there's a possibility I don't know I'm
gonna bring it to the Rose let's get
right into it we go get into also
horizon zero doing right with it but
like like developing last of us this is
to me the beginnings of a paradigm shift
it really is it to me it's and I said it
before Sony so one's gonna dip their toe
in little by little not the way that
Microsoft was just out of done it you're
not gonna see first party games and date
and PS now yet it's boogie baby
they're doing it you know whether it's a
horizon you're darn right it's it
becomes the PC this year to be three
years from from its original launch
right and you know maybe that's how they
want to do it where they're they're
still giving this this sort of a
perceived value to the people who
purchase their console but at the end of
the day I think it's a positive thing
across gaming like I'm gonna be frank
with you guys like for me what I
understand the console war stuff when
you were a little kid right right I can
understand that I we were young people
like I said I got Nintendo whatever and
even then it wasn't like I was hitting
on the other dude for what because I
didn't like what he had I was hating
because I wanted it and I couldn't get
it right when you're little right
you had you get the one whatever
sometimes you'll be able to get the two
and then but as soon as I had the
ability myself to get whatever I want
I got everything because this is not a n
it was funny to me like when when cog
you brought me onto the the podcast I'm
like this console war stuff is still a
thing I didn't know cuz I'm like I'm
like I was surprised I said people
having this conversation still don't
it's fun to it's fun to talk back and
forth about fanboys on both sides of the
other fence right what the end of the
day if you love gaming this is the best
for gaming at the end of the day what
matters is the games no no this is not
the best for gaming I do not want my
last of us on some PC are you eating my
cookies yeah based off of my cookies no
good for you why why should they give up
their precious commodities because you
know once they start going to PC they
have nothing left
don't they work on PCs to make games and
what I just did said that Nvidia mention
though because we do know the
architecture is different that would
that be why you have AMD make species so
if your new consoles going to be based
on AMD Hardware it would make sense that
you the PC you're working on is based on
mdhil why would you have an NVIDIA PC
there's absolutely no reason to have any
understand Naughty Dog goes that extra
level for no particular reason if they
let me know straight up listen we stick
a tide and you guys trying to lock us
into one box we want PC money made you
have to understand Sony can make it run
on anything and they just choose not to
write but let me what again Brad not
Sony's first for wait for a it's a PC
they did it in previous gen that is true
I want to get you this like a bear cuz I
thing that would be if this is to be
true right which it looks pretty
LinkedIn is a legit source like right
would you think what cuz walk in we
gotta jump into Ron's they were known as
well right the news came out Schreyer
put it out
it's come most likely coming out this
year I believe me Randall Thor put it
out I'll just jump on back to Lou ran up
dog took tremendous abuse I put a
Twitter tweet out he got personally
attacked it was crazy and now it's
seeming to be true Jason Schreyer also
confirmed what he had up put out already
put out on ILP that was a series X
episode but um I want to say with that
Nunes right a lot of arm Sony fanbase
would say okay they didn't necessarily
like it right some people are very upset
some people were like look well that's
it three year old game right first now
got to know the game they can get a
money
blah blah blah somebody being develop
this early right
would that what do you think this is
ultimately setting up a change of
philosophy that thing I may come earlier
to peace I don't think he's a three year
gap that's for sure definitely not a
three year gap I mean no no maybe one
year yeah listen you know shout out to
my man Jim Ryan with the dance moves
you do understand his the way he's
switch up on you know he's doing his
step he's break into a freestyle likes
going to do philosophy
your days on Jim Ryan is jamaica's
minimis I love the fact that he's in
pocket my man is in pocket
he's not playing you guys are starting
to cry see the tears all over the
Twitter keyboards I see you crying right
now you're looking yeah yo yo yo your
baseless fights are now washed away with
your tears and I'm loving it so much the
fact that this last it was true came out
just like this on the Lord's Day this
was exactly what they gave me like I
came in with a different type of ammo
with bang bang single Street gang early
good early this is what we're talking
about the knees of mine I told you what
was gonna happen and how it was gonna
happen and now you little fanboys is all
messed up
I told you just put an actual top of
your box give you credit King I have to
say one thing and I normally not want to
do this sort of thing but mm-hmm
this is a crap game or curse baby always
works but I mean yeah this definitely
surprised me you know um
this early to see that kind of you know
say they're looking for that right now
so to me what I see that you're looking
for if you're telling people that you're
trying to hire on your brand-new game
then we want you to start working with
in conjunction with a PC port have that
level of experience that it's not the
tech that is going to be used in PS 5 it
definitely supports that it's going to
PC the question is when right so if that
is the case to me again I am guessing it
would assume that that development would
be earlier than three years and a baby
right so the question now becomes like
king just sex
day and date do we think Sony will ever
get to that point because we all against
you know I'm saying Microsoft has told
their base what the philosophy is where
it's gonna go that it's gonna
on every device is gonna be on PC now do
you think this is with horizon or is
this Sony saying yo we getting y'all
ready for what eventually may come or
you still think they'll keep their old
method methodology of still not day and
date like - I think they're taking baby
steps in that direction but I think
eventually you have to get there because
when you think about when is your game
when is the the hype around the game at
its at its highest right the first week
or two after launch right obviously if
somebody drops a game record like a God
of War right and again a god of war gets
a PC port next year right or late this
year or something like that it's gonna
sell because it's got a war right right
but how much more with AI this is me
just maybe I'm wrong about this how much
more we got a war sold across the board
if it's available on other platforms
right at launch right or at least a PC
platform right at launch its it you're
gonna sell an insane amount of money up
front right same file of copies up front
all and I think as if they don't have
something akin to a game pass right if
please now doesn't doesn't evolve into
something that's more like game pass
which by the very virtue of those games
constantly being there and being sort of
pushed to the forefront and had being in
the conversation if they do something
like to do a piece now where things
rotate in it out on short intervals
right they're not gonna have the base
there to be able to create buzz around
an old game to resell it much later much
later than launch right so unless they
do that they then you have to start
considering well maybe we're selling it
we have to sell it across more than one
platform at launch to get the most out
of it right right that's my thing Oh get
that super chat real quick stitch 66 69
with the $5 super chat so cog what
happened with let's think about the kids
message because these gaming can be very
might be honest of you
here's the thing with me is that you
know she understands today put over here
at the aisle or crest up on on Twitter
today's salute that relevant and no no
switch topic so you'll be happy today
the way I look at it is we're always
talking about King or each other
it's just antiquated picking you know
like an too quickly the people who are
in their feelings about you know Sony
putting their exclusives on PC they're
in the business of making money and they
see sometimes Sony will dip their foot
is first right I don't think they're
dipping their foot I don't think they
have the resources capable to move in a
manner that Microsoft does Microsoft
build this philosophy from day one to be
honest with you right we had this
overarching brand and honey was going to
build it to get to a point a from point
A to point B right on Sony is kind of
doing it haphazardly in the manner of
they didn't have the infrastructure set
in place for the PlayStation now and and
and how it should have been going
forward right but I think they have
changed their philosophies in how
they're going to use it right
so we all know I believe date and date
is a thing is its it doesn't hurt to
have your game date and date on multiple
areas of purchase it only helps that
same game now any time somebody who
joins into your ecosystem that game is
new to them right no matter the Cosmo or
particular I have a PC you know it still
purchased into your ecosystem and
they're part of your ecosystem so when
you decide to say that oh no I don't
want my game to be played or multiple
venues listen that's the selfish
mentality because overall asking for
your company to die right right
if if you play on PC and somebody's
playing on PS 5 or ps4 or whatever that
doesn't affect you but the fact that you
get to play together does affect you
right and this is how it affects you
because it puts more eyes on your
product well it's not your product is a
product that you went out and purchased
that you are in
in the same way the pc guy is enjoying
it right now my thing is this or sony
guys upset that the game will be played
better on PC and they're getting the
inferior version of the game here's the
five shout to face 2014 he said all the
Disney put rise of Skywalker day 1 and
Disney play ok and and alright so they
have different passes right good friends
the movie theaters are doing this thing
now that if you purchase into their type
of us a service that you can go see any
movie at any time right so that's a
service that they have if Disney Plus
was doing a service like that to
circumvent the movie theater the
industry that kept them alive for
forever which would be ignorant to be
honest with you but let's just say for
argument's sake they did that how much
do you think that service will cost you
would you pay for that service would you
pay fifty sixty dollars a month that
every movie that they drop date and date
you can watch right there on your
television so that that won't be
conducive to overall sales in the movie
theater but if that is allowed to happen
then find that will work for those
individuals that chooses to purchase
into that part but you're asking from a
video game company day and day to put it
into their streaming service their
environment there's something that they
control that they get a hundred percent
of the profits back this is not a game
stop cycle situation where money is
being exchanged and they're getting no
profit of it the developers and the
company gets all of the profit they get
all of the engagement so if it's on PC
or PlayStation it's a benefit for that
platform I don't understand why
individuals are in such an uproar if the
game come out date and date it does not
affect you it just gave you an option on
where you can purchase it at you know
shout out to all bash out the gay before
it's a to lots of PC fans rejoice we
getting close to the ruling of the ball
I shot the clutch man with the file on a
super chap people hate with Microsoft
let let them sell games to cut customers
on both generation consoles and PCs more
calm more copy sold equals more money
and quick money means sequels sooner I
think you may be learning something with
that you're all busy thing and well
everyone said antiquated thinking is
that again the a lot of times I I feel
that the Sony fanbase is so used to the
old mantra which is you know exclusive
games make you buy the console right and
then the console sales is the ultimate
you know I guess quantify the ultimate
stat in as far as success is concerned
but what we're learning shot the map is
can tell the MVD is that ecosystems is
actually the new wave now we want you in
our ecosystem you want you part of
PlayStation now we want you part of all
they say anything like you said King
like ultimately this is about making
money so if they are making more money
by having it on PC if you're a console
gamer let's just call it 100 and you
have no intention of buying a PC why
does that affection why does that affect
you it should not affect you so the
thing that it's like this you know
squeezing the puffy couldn't central
it's mine no one could have it's mine
like bro it's a millions of people
who've never gonna get a chance to
experience this game that does not
affect you you're still enjoying your
PlayStation 4 exclusive on your console
and have why is that affecting your fun
you should never allow a good another
group to experience a game get you upset
like why is that good I don't know why
is bro individuals feel is not good for
Deb's that their game is being exceeding
they're being purchased more even with
the game like that these guys are
getting money upfront based on to
project the sales of their game so that
that's out of the question it just comes
down to an old mentality that in order
to buy consoles it has to be exclusive
right when I say exclusives don't have
value that's not what I'm not saying but
at the end of the day it's not the
number one driver like it used to be
they are all about this software system
exactly I mean that's the thing they
were so
the identity of the brand with the box
and that that's a stupid thing to do
right and I it doesn't make any sense
anymore because when you think about how
expensive games are to making this day
in date right it is a mirror it's a
miracle that more devs haven't gone
under it's a miracle
so how do you you have to find a way to
make the dissemination of these games
across all of the gaming sphere mm-hmm
as as easy and as consumer friendly as
possible because we're the ones that
keep it afloat we're the ones that keep
rope I love I love the tech and in these
boxes I love it and but it all comes
together if you're selling more games
and if you're able to sell more games
across the board right you're gonna
continue to get these these boxes that
you like to play them on mm-hmm because
at some point if that is not the case
and and and isolating your games to two
to one piece of hardware means that
you're making less money overall then we
will come in closer and closer to this
this platform agnostic future where
literally everything is just a service
and you can stream it on a phone or you
can do this all that stuff is coming
right but but believe you me the
continuation of the of a console as a
box under your TV is directly correlated
to how well the games in these ecosystem
sell right if and if you can sell more
and be more profitable by putting it on
other platforms you need to do it for
the sake of gaming as a whole it's
Schreyer he actually brought it back
into what you were saying I think I came
back to Mike a little bit I don't know
if there's someone but anyway um all
right so what he says for most
publishers the release of a game or PC
is no big deal right he said but most
video games always try to put the
company try to put the software how many
platforms as possible he said but for
Sony this is a remarkable move since the
launch of the PlayStation 1 in 1994 just
about every game funded and developed by
Sony has been exclusive to a Playstation
platform
Sony strategy has always been in the
past to drive hardware sales with
software and vice versa one would expect
them to take the same approach at future
games he said
what mr. bat piscatella said which one I
talked about he said the future of video
game lies in ecosystems not platforms I
like Sony's biggest competitor Microsoft
has been more upfront about its platform
agnostic strategy he said with Phil
Spencer talking about one to get games
and in many hands as possible for the
past couple of years Microsoft has
released all of its Xbox games on PC as
well will Sony follow suit with its own
state of PlayStation exclusive this
upcoming PC port of horizon may be a
telling sign which is what we're talking
about they could be changing something
they've never seen the second boy got in
the office soon as the end man he kicked
all dude out he came how on PlayStation
now was if you don't see the philosophy
is completely different you're insane if
you don't see the fact that he's pushing
the company into a new stratosphere and
taking it out of the dark ages I mean
you're not in the closet no more what
they're trying to do is they trying to
open the doors for all the developers
and trying to make sure that that money
keeps coming in if they do not change
they will be left behind Oh what are you
looking for you're looking to become
data East do you understand at this
point in time consoles are looked at as
antiquated they don't want the
livingroom space that you need to
eliminate us as you see what stay Deus
whole mantra is staking your whole
mantra is you see the commercial the guy
sticks this little finger in a window
and boots your console out of the window
so if you don't think companies don't
want to to do the manufacturing costs
for consoles you want to deal with any
of that if they can click a switch and
you can play their games without them
have to insert sell you a console that
they have to build from scratch they
have to do research and development they
have to get this tech into your hands if
they could eliminate that barrier from
making at Tech and use all those
resources to put them on service
something you don't physically own
that's magic yeah
like you can't be sleeping Eliab rap
with the $2 it's about exclusives on
ecosystems now yes you are correct sir
she's a lot's of crazy made gaming with
the $2 super chat hanging out with the
ILP on the Lord's Day let's go what sure
and we have set out to braaap again with
the $2 super chat this was a tug of war
between Laden and Ryan absolutely about
the philosophy playstation philosophy
moving forward and shout out to face 23
NY just cuz Microsoft had to change the
narrative doesn't mean Sony doesn't have
to have to follow suit exactly to the T
day and date won't happen for a while
I'll agree I agree it won't happen for a
while but they they like on the road to
it Joe Evan you got a really eat that
one right there
cuz I can't wait till this date and date
and then you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna be so petty i'ma let my petty hang
out so crazy boy I'm gonna go and make
sure if listen let me tell you some
photo before you go in finish that last
one from Brad to find out Brad with the
files of a chat gamers discuss times are
changing streaming is the future no more
console exclusives exit etc
Nintendo hold my beer then they tend
those still held oh yeah right now
they're definitely role defer Last of Us
2 comes out date and date on PC my petit
gonna hang pause and I'm buying a PC
version of the Last of Us 2 just to turn
you guys up a million just I'm a 42 and
then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
install it and I'm gonna let it boot up
with all the patches and all the fun and
I'm gonna record myself playing last it
was 2 on PC it becomes dating game oh no
there's plank playing devil's advocate
for a moment I think there is a
possibility that maybe it's not
- that's coming to PC and maybe they're
just looking to hire someone who has
that as a long-term potential goal
mm-hmm the Job Description does say we
want you to be part of our team for Last
of Us part two specifically you never
say that's the only thing that draws me
with graphic pulla but I mean again
great assault
like you said eka mean we can't take it
1,000% but the indicator to tell us what
the rule is this particular game and
quacks like a judge talk about it as a
sheep no look at you right now
izes going quack crap if you want our
game is perfect that's a river in Egypt
you my friend are actually get right
back to anchor because um this is
something again you know saying a king
brought to the table and one of your
favorite games obviously is the order
again this one is a little sketchy you
know saying but the rumor is from a
proposal II some you know high profile
sauce who's been right in the past if
it's tie ducks it's a lie yeah I mean
this is actually no this is some
Osiris's but the rumor is you know ready
at dawn he's thinking about bringing the
order 1886 with a sequel and that the
sequel will be or will be multiplayer so
it got to the point that Eve it was on
GamesRadar and um even Colin Moriarty he
had responded to it actually he had said
you know the game had potential the team
was too focused on the tech to make the
product and so truly shine and Sony was
frustrated with the process behind the
scenes for ready at dawn to get another
crack and go multiplayer Sony would have
to
Lync wish the IP but then he says
stranger things have happened
so what are you saying obviously I know
you're a huge order 1886 fan one of the
biggest I know like what do you feel
about it the potential would you like it
don't think it's realistic we're way out
with this I hope I can hope and dream do
I think it's real I put it on par with
the people saying rise to is gonna
happen okay okay mm like it's it's
basically the same kind of scenario I
really hope it would happen
mm-hmm I just I just don't know if it
will I don't you do not get the
reception that it needed right to be
like weren't like it it may be one thing
cuz it did not sell great and didn't
have good critical reception right the
problem is I don't think I didn't get
like cult status later either so just I
don't I can't see Sony bringing it back
I mean they have plenty of their own
titles that they aren't bringing back
that had critical success or became cult
favorites but I mean it evil came back
Vudu Vince came back to JD okay so
without the JD game with the $5 super
chat let me slide through to the ILP
pause I have been killing these fools
King throw them in the bushes these PS
fanboy suicide anchorman is auditioning
for Sony's new flute mix I'm waiting for
III 2021 baby this is ridiculous yeah I
mean stranger things have happened look
listen uh once you separate it from
Activision and they let them keep
destiny um
ah anything can happen and in like Anka
said if they if sony Sony have been the
ones to be to nurture IP right you come
out with over the first with the first
shot and wasn't the greatest but there's
potential there actually 1886 the lore
in that game everything that's in that
world is fantastic this the game was
derivative and not it just did it wasn't
super fun to play but everything else
around it was a fake I was me people did
not like the game because it was not the
$60 experience they were hoping for it
was really short it weren't for me I
paid $8 for it that was the best I mean
that you said that Sony was so forceful
with them in the background as far as
maxing out the tech and you know at the
launch of the system because they were
so consumed with showing the power of
the PlayStation 4 and not written to
calm the company gradually grow into the
power you believe that hurt the overall
game I think it was more because they
were being a tech demo game and I I
don't believe the whole oh yeah Sony
like we're starting like trying to rush
them or something like that I think they
were I think they were largely they knew
this was a tech demo game do you feel
that them using that projection point to
maximize the power of the system hurt
the overall design of a game that could
have been a whole lot more fun had they
been allowed to grow into the tech
instead of displaying the tech in the
first six months of the content is that
no piece of software at the launch of a
console it's really showing the power
this is it's not showing anything I mean
if you got a you know bigger sprites you
know different resolution blah blah blah
this that stuff on the unit in third I
love the order okay let me try I thought
the or
what top-notch gaming was it beers
beater hell no no it wasn't even the
string st. stratosphere is good but the
game looked fantastic the game actually
showed you what the PlayStation can do
and I think it actually suffered from
that whole aspect of their mandate that
they felt that they had to live up to a
tech demo philosophy and I think that's
Shrunk the game in in in size and scope
that hurt the game work and it could
have been a cult classic it could have
been that game that lived on in a
Playstation ecosystem but these
PlayStation dudes were so consumed with
power and trying to show something that
it actually hurt the overall product and
I think the philosophy that Microsoft
has going forward where they allow their
companies to grow into the tech and
during the transition year you get a
chance to play these games through
cross-gen and cross platforms and it can
actually grow so when the companies do
release these games and that force
there's no guns that they had they don't
have to live up to some mantra that you
guys are putting on their back with
showing power first day and date you're
gonna see something different you're
going to see different type of particle
effects you're gonna see if you actually
have a 4k television you're gonna
actually see 4k 60 graphics so I believe
that the philosophy is antiquated and
it's a really good product
I love the werewolf law I live world but
I mean what's fantastic about that game
coming to Microsoft now we'll have a
chance to live in game pass we'll
definitely have a home where you guys
shunned it you got the power y'all got
the tech y'all had everything right
there and you took it for granted
now it's up for dibs now show you how to
hug the game how to love a game and make
sure part two is well-received game pass
[Music]
you don't have to take the bus no more
no no more same at the bus stop get
ready adores the next video and IOP if
that's a situation you know what's our
watch really happy dawn is ready in
pocket you just wrap it up pack it up
and put an X on that bonnet and it goes
back it goes back to that that that
feeling like that is truly a change in
philosophy in the wind because it's like
it back at it did you see you will see
so many nurture a game that was soso and
turned it into a mega franchise and
that's exact opposite of what Marcus
over dude
like if it didn't sign out the door it
was kicked you know when you have when
you're thinking about your ecosystem as
something that lives across generations
of hardware and across different
platforms you can look at smaller games
you can look at games that have not been
you know given the chance to pass they
deserve the perhaps we're just just hat
did not get eyes on it you can give it a
chance right in a way that's not like to
you are you saying throw that on PC it
should be going beatin PC to court on PC
you know Phil's still have it you know
when he talked about game pass and
putting stuff episodically on game pass
in order to just sort of to absorb cost
that still hasn't happened yet right and
I still think we get a game like that at
some point see definitely driving game
pass this is what you're saying listen
if you put the order 1886 out on PC and
Xbox right now that's another I would
say it easily and you sell it for $19.99
right listen first of all I don't
don't cheap out on me all right
you put it on xbox game pass right
ultimate right and if you want to
purchase it elsewhere on PC then a
twenty dollar game whatever wait wait
wait um I need to be clear for youto buy
the first one you can tell me more
copies or the file switch at these
PlayStation fan boys holding out for day
and date on the lonely island there last
bastion of glory it's over for them the
curse is upon them
face 23 BK and wow the father shot clap
back same way you guys won Sony at e3
and that's happening daddy happening for
a while if ever is the same way
Sony ain't doing date and date for a
long time he hold it firm y'all he liked
it he would not have you to do the drink
the kool-aid talked about they don't
need to be at e3 listen listen that that
that conversation of them not needing a
beer
each week we bought the game today but
you did it everybody as well it's a
clearly it's right dealer I don't know
what's gonna happen with the order 80 to
83 whatever he takes excuse me but um
you know it is interesting that this
came up we'll see how true it is I would
like the game you know it would be cool
different for I guess series X or
whatever but we shall see if Sony
relinquished the IP or not but we we
gotta talk about the beta Batman and um
yeah which is III and Sony skipping III
again so a statement has been made I
shot two games industry diabase who put
out the information salute to those guys
do great work um after thorough
evaluation si he has decided not to
participate in the e3 2020 we have a
great respect for the ESA
as an organization but we do not feel
the vision of III 2020 is the right
venue for what we are focused on this
year we will build upon our global event
strategy in 2029 but is it a they're not
focused on games oh I thought
three is about B hey I'm getting mixed
messages I don't understand Gaston
activations global strat strategy 2020
by participating in hundreds of
communica mute consumer events across
the globe hundreds of community events
is Papa John's our focus is on making
sure our fans feel part of the
PlayStation family and we have access to
play their favorite content we have a
fantastic lineup of titles coming to
PlayStation 4 and with the upcoming your
anchor I'm about to tear this building
with the upcoming launch of Playstation
5 we are truly looking forward to a year
of celebration with our fans and then I
believe the ESA clap back and said in
response to them we say e 3 is a
signature event celebrating the video
games industry showcasing the people the
brands the innovation and basically they
basically saying we still gonna be
exciting we're still high energy show
it says Sony broke it couldn't play to
build so they skipped out on it when you
going to go book an Airbnb and then you
hit the uh let me reserve that wait a
second why did the price switch oh it's
I can't afford that
we at this point in time our focus will
be on other things because you know
we're gonna spread it out through a
hundreds of games that we do it letting
all these Xbox hating PlayStation
fanboys will kick the door down then and
let them in don't worry place is your
fan it's safe in here ok fire a fire
today
JD's on fire today but on listen you
know the news came down very fast you
know they're not gonna be at e3 again
you know a lot of people who had assumed
a they would be obviously places 5 a big
console launch let's set it off with
solve
first because I think I do anchoring a
kid get going so let's get let's get us
off I'll be when the news broke
what's your feeling is this a mistake
are you cool with it that's only have
the right to do how move how they want
to move where you at with this whole
situation I have the right to move why
they want to move but it's disappointing
it's disappointing because it's like you
know listen I I agree that in a lot of
ways III is antiquated and what I mean
by that is that they still haven't
they're still in that gray area where
they haven't figured out how to
transition from purely a trade show and
making it a fan centric show right
they're still not packs they're working
on that I'm not sure that the direction
they're going is is necessarily that but
you do have to make it so that it is a
viable place where people really want to
go and they know they're gonna be able
to actually play games and then so it
it's a it's a matter of evolving it to
make it appealing to both publishers and
devs and gamers to come and I'm not
saying that's an easy thing but they're
not there yet so in that sense yes
definitely it's antiquated that said I'm
disappointed they're not going this year
because the console logs here not they
have such a history with with announcing
and launching consoles and not launching
Council but announcing consoles and
blowing them out at e3 it's
disappointing that they're not at least
for the up for me for the fans going to
do that head-to-head thing with
Microsoft disappoint I don't care what
the politics behind it are or the
economics behind it are I don't care but
they should be there this year tire
strategy Sony's used to going after
Microsoft and you're just gonna skip
that whole conference so they have time
to tell you I would tell you this I
would tell you this if they were to come
back right and I'm Microsoft I'm like no
I'm going second mmm you relinquish your
spot I'm going second just in case I
have to rebut in some way shape or form
just to go second because of the fact of
how the timing is in Japan I always
thought that put them at an advantage
because Microsoft based in the United
States they went first because they are
home turf and and you know Sony always
went second because of the time
difference between Japan and the United
States because they wanted maximum eyes
because that is their home turf
they wanted their home people to
actually see their conference and stuff
like that's all I never thought that it
was thought of strategically it was just
a byproduct of being in a different time
zone that actually helped them and and
it turned into an advantage to be honest
with you know he does yeah when you have
the ability to put something together in
an hour to rebut something we sort that
to this debt to this day is a me write
this days of thing I think it matters
um what about what about this all in and
it says that um you know you know
they're not gonna be there right
you know but what about I guess my issue
you know saying let's get to it
is that even Nintendo doesn't do the
traditional II
press a press conference right but they
have a presence on the floor right they
have a direct during the week my problem
last year was that okay I get it
I do get it with Sonia say even though
I'm disappointed as a gamer I want Sony
to be there I get it you know if it you
don't feel it's beneficial you don't
want to financially I even I'll even
give throw King a bit bone
if you financially don't want to spread
that bread to to for that boot space and
all like I get it my question then is
like why can't you have a dedicated
event that's off-site myself does the
only thing off-site immunity or even if
you don't want to pay for the event you
can do the Sony stay to play during that
week the problem I had is there's no
presents oh oh no video no nothing for
the fans and my main concern is this and
I know people say oh it's antiquated is
always dead I get that but if you're a
fan of the PlayStation branch shout out
to 200 people in watching live exactly
the question I have is just like don't
you want a fan they haven't done a fan
of it in a while and the things that
they've done has either been
isolated to their own or jet for the
press like isn't the PAP SX was canceled
I believe 2018 or whatever whatever you
know it is just one of those things I
just want them to have a fan event to
showcase cuz we know where they're gonna
do the reveal right reveals most likely
or intended purses
it looks like February and that's cool
we are saying we're gonna get the
present five we're gonna see what it is
but it's just sad that you can't do
anything with the fans can go hands-on
you know post PlayStation 5 launch and
say oh his gaze whatever
beside unless it be a third party and
that and that coupled with the fact and
we said this before it's like they've
gotten away from having personalities
and and and and it's like not in the way
that Microsoft like everybody's a
personality at Microsoft whether it be
you know it's like it's like they don't
it's just very weird because this in
this type of Industry it's fan driven
right you have to you have to engage you
don't have to engage with the people
buying Sony Vega you know you don't have
to but you but when it comes to gaming
you need somebody up there to be the
face of it and to engage with people and
to put a face book it is box and it's
like it doesn't make a lot of sense to
me and like you said I don't even care
if it's if it's like a direct style
thing just give me something nice know
that this is the place where people even
those gamers are gonna be looking at in
June like this is always always the case
right look and I understand like the
Internet is is what it is the Internet
allows you to touch however many people
in at the drop of a hat
mm-hmm but it's not the same thing and
so as long as this venue continues to
exist particularly in a console launch
year I think it's I think it just sucks
they're not there and you try we got
some super trash out Disney the files of
a chat solely concluded Phil Spencer
ain't about to have a Don Mattrick
mustache so they couldn't crack back now
with how to share game jokes some
pointed trm
do you want to get Raymond Morel also
okay that I'm around with the fat our
super chat eiope
panel do you feel Microsoft will pull
their punches at EC 2020 like 2019
because no Sony presence I don't know
you feel sorry baby
no well at the start of this generation
we talked about how Sony did never take
the boot off the neck no matter what
like Microsoft could be hanging out in
the corner quiet and they would just
walk by them and mush them for no reason
right like stick and keep the boot on
the neck and yeah I would love to see
Microsoft do that and be like no we're
gonna we're gonna blow out everything
that we have to talk about we're not
holding anything back for anything we'll
just as as events move on we'll be go
into more detail on the things that we
that we talked about at e3 that's my
hope
and I think I agree with King I think
they need to take that mentality like
listen if this is gonna be it we need to
be aggressive and act like we're the
ones putting the boot on the neck right
well right now he is the one putting the
boot on the neck right now
everything that they do it is a rebuttal
we give you a 24-hour notice on your
neck and um let's get at it
let's pray they didn't have any games to
show at e3 there was a little refine
your old simple and all this other stuff
so that was the reasoning right and then
these PlayStation heads was talking all
that well they're gonna come back next
year bigger better bolder boy look at
you now look at you now sitting your
sauce sauce and stew because you talked
all that hot boy stuff talking about
they was coming with all this smoke and
they told you straight up
we are not there so last year the
excuses they didn't have any games I
didn't have nothing new to sell or
nothing new to show they got a new show
now so we're gonna keep that same energy
from last year we're gonna put it on
this year all England's PlayStation 4
stuff and enhance stuff that's gonna go
to PlayStation 5 and they know they
can't go up to the stadium talking about
yeah you know we got these old games you
get your Little Mix no because Microsoft
is showing you new stuff last year the
Microsoft showed you all head rock
bangers and they didn't even go hard on
you pause they said maybe they put out
those names they showed you okay this is
what's gonna come out through the year
they twisted a stuff around just to fit
the format cuz dudes was scared to box
so right now Marcus off is like oh you
don't wanna throw no punches they trying
to TK oh you sure you think going into
this e3 right here your man is gonna
wear kid gloves on you no not at all
he's gonna take the lining out and knock
yo Joe's complete trouble right now
because what you gonna come with last of
us again what are you gonna do Last of
Us remix what do you wanna do
so God full what come on is on PC get
away from me games for you they would if
they do company right if that were the
case in if they were to come to ithi
right they would have to talk basically
only about new stuff because everything
that they have on the calendar is
essentially coming out before right well
except for goats Africa so let me let me
let lets play fair for the sake of
argument with the ps4 I revealed that we
know is common right so we do that we do
the specs we know more logo we got the
logo out the way but we do respects we
do the hard way do the visual you know
say I don't know if we get the price
whatever but what if they showcase an
exclusive game that many don't know
about and wouldn't they be able to
galvanize they base just like that for
the people to say they don't need III
like if they just did that and then and
then walk off then I don't want to do
now I think they do I think they have
something but again game was that
shooting game show you Killzone actually
look like the trailer did this show the
last time you actually play like this
you can get smashed in at the reformed
told it to us at e3 2020 breaking news
Sony tweeted so we are all in agreement
that appreciation is not showing up to
eat me because Microsoft was like we not
showing our hand first we want to go
second and PlayStation
like by your game gamer Oh control
behind the chat wait a minute you get
good thank you they gave me a thought
what Tony actually did that good what
like they go out there and they say hey
yeah we know we're out of three but
here's a picture of the console by like
this I mean they still could make some
type of you know singular statement
whether it be the price you don't have
saying or all and show that VR dough
this is what I'm talking about
you got my joint in a box show that V
all man let me move my VR man don't give
me that whack I'm your man you set it up
man you are man you call me X but now I
got that Playstations I got more
PlayStation stuff than you shut up see
that design oh my god that's real I
never want to hear anybody talk about
the series X like not fitting in their
spawn ever cooler will be horrible with
that is off the phone what specs nine
still less than twelve allegedly
allegedly pushes you got the bushes
going you know I mean I hear what you're
saying I mean it's just like I said just
from a fan's perspective up this where
I'm a kid you know you got the right as
Sony to nacho right you've got you've
earned that right ESA has got I'm not
sure ESA just got doxxed
from Sony everybody got a person like
Sony be out there talking to friends
like they do you will walk down the
street and see Major Nelson you can see
Phil and everybody outside you don't
ever see Sony is sequestered inside some
building some place and nobody knows in
the core some place I don't act like be
out there running around a month nobody
cares about nothing we probably don't
even know the names they were six months
of PSN I mean so he's used to that
all of cities and I'll be a penny Oh fun
yes all I'll say is that edited day
they've earned the right to say look yes
a we don't like which or and yes it is
going like that you keep saying they
earn something you keep giving these dog
dudes a back dog tell your friends and
give them a thumb up like all I'm saying
is the ESA part that we could say your
family we're not showing it on your
stage okay right but we could do it on
our stage on our building how we want to
do we ain't got to pay you no bread
right we'll do what we got to do
oh I'm with you King I'm just saying I'm
mad they're not doing that let me ask
you a question
yeah they don't show anything on a stage
they have their own Sony building that
they show they pay stuff on same thing
on Microsoft it's not like they they
they're renting space from the SI toos
show and the conference is off-site now
what you're saying is this is the part
where I'm telling you they didn't earn a
damn thing because when I go inside the
convention hall and I'm going from hall
a to Hall B I want to see your presence
on the floor right no respect to the
people at our patreon yo product and
show the respect to the developers that
are actually supporting your product you
shouldn't respect to anybody that kids
to come out to make that fan week
important but they're not showing any
respect to this community in any form of
fashion they're telling you we're gonna
do some little Taco Bell craps
throughout the year and that's not
working with me John I mean I paid this
money to go to e3 I don't want to see
you show up I want to see you represent
and if Nintendo is actually on the floor
which they have a huge presence don't
give it to mr. people keep saying on
Nintendo does it show no conference
listen boy there are they're there on
the floor in and we actually touch their
product games that's a fact sofa if Sony
is not on the floor if they have no
presence they're thumbing named nose to
you that has Ted they telling you
basically you want to buy
matter what if we Sherman not what part
disloyalty that you given to somebody
that dad's our indifference to you if if
you was dating a girl that didn't care
if you came around I didn't okay
whatever you did you will leave that
girl alone but you very much by the
Baggies what about dubgame buddy
whatever they say but she give me the
game of the year badness that's why I
really show up every three years like
she do to you go to her every three
years like I do my my joint got dust on
it in the back so every three years when
a banger comes out I throw to bang on
I play it I see off a little bit and she
got to go right back to the bushes
that's not somebody that you sit there
spend time with all the time because
she's not getting nothing back to you I
like hugs and kisses baby if you're not
giving me hugs and kisses I don't want
to have nothing to do with you absorb 72
hours which at ESA DS solely more than
solely leaves the ESAC they don't get
them they always be brainwashed to death
when you go in three this year shout out
to the the cellular group that we have
going to III that's in the compound with
us shout out to these individuals that
are fantastic those names will be
released if they want to be released
later but when you go to e3 mmm
I want you to tell me your statement
after going to e3 have to see in
everybody there after seeing everything
I want you to tell me your true honest
opinions cuz right now you're talking
from a state of not-knowing
but after you know I want you to tell me
how you felt going to a conference
that's all about games and that
individual did not show up because they
said that you purchase in anyway
whenever we drop we got you a pocket and
there's nothing you could do about
sitting there talking about yeah this is
you know what I'm saying I'm down with
that
she called I'm coming straight Superman
in the face
the only reason why I cop day one is
because I can now if it was a situation
and I had to choose if I only had duck
it's for one situation I'm at right now
I'm going with the boo to keep kissing
me I'm not somebody to show up every
three years with God of War no man you
don't come every three years and think
I'm gonna support you 100%
that's not gonna happen like that and
this year they gave you concrete genie
and you had the key tag and all the way
do you got nothing speaking of that I
actually have a good question about that
you're talking about earlier how Sony
normally will foster and support these
new IPs when they come out and I think
that's largely true if their successes
right but my question is under the Jim
Ryun leadership what about these games
have been around for you they're working
for about four years now right and they
don't do too hot so my question is like
what's gonna happen to Sony Bend when
you say it's mediocre but it's sold very
well so you'll get another you'll get
another day's come on you are gonna get
that but when you look at like when you
look at like a concrete genie right just
the way that they just the way they
marketed those games pass only would
have put those games concrete genie the
medieval remaster right those are the
old fact that it's particularly medieval
and old franchise they would have
brought to the forefront and at least oh
it came out around Halloween there was
nothing around that game hey there you
go Oh Tony wouldn't have done that right
so it begs to it bastes the question
will they have the same level of
tolerance for mediocre performances
moving forward after kick deck he said
tell us which a king purchased games not
trade shows the reality is 90% of the
consumer base knows nothing of these
shows and still buy games consoles
regardless of whether they show up I
refute what you're saying I don't
believe 90% doesn't know about
these trade shows first of all when you
get there you're on your end you keep
talking from a position of not knowing
but this year we're gonna open your eyes
now you purchase games when you get into
that game show I'm gonna put that camera
on you and I'm gonna go live on you he's
talking from a position of not knowing
don't let these dudes fool you a lot of
these dudes don't go because they can't
go and and they're not in a position to
go but if they had the chance to go they
will break their legs to get there so
let's let's stop acting like this is the
Super Bowl they wouldn't know about III
I would I would say listen I'm gonna
jump back on now I'm gonna get to yeah I
just wanna say you know the thing I'm
gonna say is reference to it is this
whole you know we're gonna build our
upon our global event strategy of 2020
and participate in all these hundred I'm
holding them to the fire on this that's
where I met the Taco Bell I want to see
fan of this that's all I'm saying this
has nothing to do with executives they
said this has this has to do with
presence on the floor showcasing your
new wares to the fans that are law you
and give you this 106 million next you a
February event that they're having for
the whole month long downtown in
Manhattan shown you old PlayStation I
mean we could go probably cuz we media
but the fans can't go that's supposed to
be there available they announced that
they're doing some joint in New York
City or a whole month showing the
PlayStation brand and you know it's
supposed to be open to fans they're not
in in February that they sending out the
little secret messages everybody come
check us out I'm talking about the one
that they announced that's in New York
City they haven't officially announced
anything okay won't talk about it I
don't know if they're gonna be about it
I hope I yes absolutely I would like old
PlayStation stuff
I'm just happy if they do something
something to be said when you go to e3
but you go to a PSX and you're there la
even even last was it 20 shot if the
finest is in the chat so to the five he
was in one year where they had it in a
movie theater or something for the fans
you don't saying it's just a community
event so many fans rocket there's one
year you know Sammy BG hip hop game all
in the joint
you're not saying like it is something
to be said for the fan that's all I'm
saying you they got together than a fan
event in a while everything has been
pressed industry that's all I'm saying
if I'm propagating there to go he said
break fighter jet let's wait to see when
Sony does before we take them to town
I'm disappointed Sony won't be at it
three but it won't stop me from buying
their products that's what he say okay
I'm telling you don't buy the products
I'm telling you or whatever you say it I
don't care about that I'm just telling
you that they're indifferent to you as a
person they're looking at you and I and
say you're gonna cop anyway why because
we released PlayStation 25 years ago so
you in and you feel that you have some
weird loyalty to a situation that is not
loyal to you I'm telling you
give back see what if Microsoft would
have took that same stance this energy
would be like this if Mike decided oh we
don't need to do any fan service they
had to scratch and claw because they got
they face broken so you sit there and
tell me oh I don't like you of
supporting that a company needs to get
punched in the mouth no when you punch
somebody in mouth they wake up as a
decision time right now it's called
fight or flight even you gonna fight or
you gonna run so I want them to fight I
want them to get punched in their mouth
right I want you to go back in a back
scene that I got punched an email flash
yeah I guess they didn't get punched in
the mouth hard enough but Phil is down
for the fight right now and if you
understand and that this man is he's
ready he got his gun is cocked
he is ready he already has those bangers
you already know compulsion just told
you we got that banger when you you just
don't really understand what's gonna
happen right now but Sony does and when
they do come out with this stuff they
better be ready for a fight because this
ain't gonna be easy this ain't that Don
Mattrick lair past
Euan crap your main goal for the LeBron
James dunk on your Mick go look in your
face is he gonna win the game I'm
telling you don't know Microsoft right
now you're listening to old Microsoft
this is a whole new wave it's a whole
new game
Sony needs to come and play all right so
I'm with you I fear we going the
response seems to be to you that the
Sony base is not that then not all of
them are not up so some people say look
III is dead they don't care wait because
they don't never go anywhere for them
it's a lot of for me okay enough fair
that fair but my question is you know
for them they say well again we're still
getting the bangers you know so is it is
it do you think it's a thing that they
have to see a drop-off in the quality of
the software for them to find out except
this non fanservice stuff I think it is
gonna be a drop-off in the quality oh I
think Sony will always deliver brand
quality okay right I'm not listen I'm
not advocating there dude for them to
fall Rafi I'm gonna Kate and for them to
stand tall to stand up for you if you're
waving a flag how my timeline is dead I
have Sony dudes all over me pause long
day y'all a crushed underfoot how do you
feel like with me Lord and over all you
PlayStation do for you heads remember
y'all used to be the trifecta all the
big dudes y'all was out here stomping
the yard Oh be careful because if you
anger this Duty I've been crushing you
dude
I'm your lord and over you so you know
all your games is going to PC remember
that philosophy had changed dance moves
Ryan now so right now he's doing all
these beautiful dance moves on you and
you can't even come at me this is I want
competition I'm driving competition and
right now competition is none all right
burn whoever come in my chamber a torch
our culture
you should have brought you neighborhood
to support
okay okay
there we have it lastly we'll be really
worried like okay this okay so this
generation I I went on my way to own
every console good wait I got afford to
do it it's great but like I'm sitting
back and I'm thinking like for next gen
okay I'm sitting here looking at my
switch my xbox and my PlayStation 4 pro
I'm sitting here looking at and I'm like
for next gen like I don't think Sony's
got anything immediate that we don't
know a little II dropped the PlayStation
5 review some crazy Bangor exclusive
that's only to them then glass of us
goes cheap on whatever I'm talking about
right now though is I'm just sitting
here thinking about what happened last
time right
where was like yeah I started the Xbox
one started with that and then I a
couple years later I got a PlayStation 4
but honestly that was probably the best
way to do it if I had not started with
the PlayStation first in that case
because I just because because they only
have the exclusives and that's it right
and especially up the series X is gonna
be more powerful toad with the file I
see what you have a lot of smack down
talk on Sony's neck while Xbox has no
exclusives for at least a year so they
have no exclusive what do you call halo
infinite hmm is exclusive to the
Microsoft platform right I mean my
question to you is you keep talking
about all these no exclusives and none
of these games years and all this stuff
okay what happened with 4s it drops we
already know what's coming up we already
know for a hamburger fries a shake is
gonna be there we know hamburger fries
this shake is dead so we got that in
back right you already know that fours
are gonna beat it you know halo is gonna
beat it and then it's gonna be another
exclusive game but the question because
you can play it on your red
Xbox do that if that works for you do
that who did therefore you don't happen
they told you yo you know what when your
pockets ready you can jump up with the
big boys but right now stay there stay
there where you where but if the big
boys you can do that tooth shut up that
he gave about choice find out uh super
check King okay King when the album drop
it he was coming soon we gotta move all
eventually but um this is a hot one I'm
with I'm with slow and a couple it be
money to chat on this way like I ready
to to write them off yet but I am
disappointed with the decision not to
shorty three you don't say at least just
have their own show even if it has
nothing to do with you say even if these
dudes to come at me come at it's it's
it's it's besides the competition which
we all love wait where you can't we come
from that right we like we come from
that day like yo I'm serious
Micah so drop I was slowly going through
he today they're cooking up in the lab
what they gonna do it was an event at e3
you know say that those are the magic
moments you miss you know saying as a
fan of someone who's going to e3 so many
times we have you know you missed that
aspect but at least if they're too did
like the Nintendo thing you know people
we still hold in front of that TV during
a Nintendo Direct y'all be laugh at me
when I'm with so yeah you're there but
we watch it you know I'm saying and it's
something to be said you go on the floor
you touch the latest things from
Nintendo you touched on even the
Microsoft has their own separate
building you touch the latest up you get
excited for the future what's to come
and you just want them to have something
similar and I just hope they do
something during that week for their
fans so even if it's just the state of
play you don't say like y'all hear it yo
here's the price Sony
400 ollars boom a date right gotta get
people back to logo like they showed us
a logo that you dudes are so brainwashed
like they showed you a logo and you
would just oh my god you know listen I
can't believe the shame I would've logo
III you say I'm not gonna be in him long
lift and alive
it is what it is you know saying we've
all we've said when we fell but we'll
see we'll see what happens now we got a
rap minutes we're going long but all
yeah oh so good right now
boy I'm on competition so any of you
Sony dudes
please go on Twitter and follow me and
King David OTW
please bring yourself over there sucker
bash your skull it get tired eh yo with
the brim you know what I'm gonna try to
UM brainwash you now I'm bringing a soap
and water and I'm gonna clean your mind
and all that don't let get into this
program you're supposed to get about it
do i oh oh with the rumors of now um
horizon zero dawn coming to PC this year
do you think this will eventually open
the door up for Sony first party
exclusive to launch day and date on PC
the choices are a this will never happen
so the first party exclusives may only
make may only release years after B yes
writing is on the wall so anyone's
profit like any other smart business or
see I don't care it's all fun and games
until it's my favorite PlayStation
reform
Tony letting it go you say fine some
checking I'm an Xbox fan but they've
disappointed me for more than arm Sony
has my bras so then what you do is you
don't play on Microsoft play on Sony do
those buggers I mean you have freedom of
choice good for you is if you really
have to understand I'm I don't care if
Microsoft did anything for you or Sony
did anything for you I gave my game you
game with you game I have it all but I
keep telling you guys I see them
whenever they release those bangers
every three years I tuned up to my
playfully it up for no lie I went up
when I booted up my PlayStation to play
a portal rock a street fight it was damn
near two hours of hell modem patches to
that's low
so d not being at e3 all good I'll be
there with ILP booms Ames boom the brat
[Laughter]
staff am gonna be in there man it's
gonna be so much fun
man they not letting us go they're not
letting us leave crazy big Amy with the
fire I super check even if Xbox would
have shown the series X logo it still
would have been something new we already
knew it was gonna be too peaceful you
know what they didn't show you just a
logo they share with you a little sizzle
reel they showed you form-factor they
gave you with that's called fanservice
not gonna give you a logo and say thank
you good night thank you we sing your
damn time they didn't waste your time
actually you it was a welcome surprise
they didn't tell you to tune into a
refrigerator service show and you waited
for hours and you was completely
disappointed no you've got a game award
show he was watching and then my den
filled ominous Maximus Spencer took to
the stage and he had that glint in his
eyes you saw that great in his eyes you
knew what was gonna happen this is going
down and they actually went now many
actually did what they were supposed to
do but Sony did it to you and you was
like this is it this is going down he's
like lobo - the Vanna White unveiling of
the new electric vehicle this is the
pettiest of cio feeling there yeah
ridiculous
yeah gonna let us leave eventually look
out ladies Nayla I just we compose the
gays that came through absolute pleasure
to see them in the building we will have
compulsion back on as they get closer to
release they definitely got something
cooking y'all so it's really cool to see
one of xbox game studios up in there man
and yeah that was that was tremendous
obviously attic hopefully we'll be back
you ever say he's doing that doing well
so please reach out to him man was
throwing up he trusts me he wanted to
make it hehe this was to show he loves
compulsion there was no way he was
missing this unless he's legit sick so
salute to our brother the young wolf
heal up bro we will get you back you
know I'm saying be money you see the
logo put the casuals or notice I am fees
at his man it's the big buddy sounding
breath yeah I know it's all jokes
against man come on yeah but um yeah
chop the anchorman for coming the two
Lords gave it got net a good man you
know same fresh off a couple of articles
and cool and everything and media will
be attending certain events for us as
well so what I give a Wicca define
people find you what you got going on so
you guys can find me on Twitter Xbox
Playstation your mic was snitch Lord
sovereign hold it down in the room as
usual what can people going to work you
know coming through I love those those
small studio acquisitions by Microsoft
to me are gonna produce big things so
I'm play we happy few we haven't played
it not in today if you're not into the
whole survival stuff but at least for
the story stories fantastic play we
happy for you no doubt shot to be my
keep doing our thing so I'll see you
guys soon anyone pulling up a keys yes
almost the majority of lords and log
that will be a taxi so if you pulling up
be money let us know man we would
definitely be there shout you out Lord
King they were away they could not wait
to hear you I got six DMS five tweets
and they were like you must talk about
The Last of Us
you must talk about Kings I keep
must here from where I can't hit turn
the beat around or your man low Q and
don't oh it's moving out here thank you
for everybody that actually watched the
video I actually went to UM log comm um
- I mean got net to actually check out
the statue let's look gaming dotnet um
listen
that's tremendous to me to be honest
with you that came all the way from
China even the UM the artists who
conceived this you know mentally and
actually gave birth to it physically hit
me up on YouTube and I was so pleased
that he was a heel he loved the video
it's a shout out to Zion art who
actually put out quality products you
can purchase from him they're a smaller
company like an indie dev you know um so
the fact that they actually putting our
total quality statues is amazing to me
you can also find me at combat talk with
tea I was like Duke ah yesterday but I
was swamped with so much stuff that I
had to get done I have a couple of
display units that you're gonna see over
here and that's the situation change a
lot I had a bunch of these pitches
because most of the stuff is going on
eBay I got over 300 400 items that's
going on eBay little stuff have to get
up and have to get out of here no longer
in the toy business you know so they
gotta go long I mean my kid don't play
with toys anyway so it doesn't matter uh
but you can find us at pax you can find
us at pax as media you can find it going
to III you can actually see us in these
streets and you can actually follow me
on twitter king david OTW and also the
same thing on xbox live okay so you jump
in hang out talk I'm at I listen I'm
going to curse them have a good time
this is a game wholly different alright
but we definitely gonna get on to make
sure you have game packs I'm not
accepting new friends unless they have
game
listen if you don't have game pads don't
add me
don't add me don't look for me don't try
to find me because if I want to play
with you in a game cause you want to
have to have the same level of
entertainment that I do like my boy
wanted to play Tekken what we did we
just popped in plate right so if you
can't move the way I move don't move
with me don't look for me don't try to
find me
alright thank oh my gosh I don't have
game you want hang out with me Oh bucket
so diff they so they can't rock with the
kick outs don't jump in my chat i'ma
check you out when I say your let's play
sniper elite or something like that
oh but you can't play with me if you
can't play with me I don't want to have
I just want gamers I want people that I
don't want you to coming to chat and
just just be there just to talk
I know we gonna play some games I wanna
play game salute to Lord the Lord of
gamepad there but I like to throw that
hit you at this way if some Road King
let you know the requirements to it have
enjoyment or that swag love with kids
figure to pay first
Yuri bill oh you can't be buddies a your
neck check it okay i'ma tell you right
now if you want some of that smoke I'm
handling it out you want some of that
smoke remember add me King David OTDR
you get that smoking no rush it is all
you say if you don't buy the game you
like don't check for him hey no Russian
you can get that smoke to get that game
passed and I can beat you up too I'm
coming in there yeah good salute
everybody around we're out of control
today fantastic show salute the lords a
gamer dinette
loving what the good guys are doing just
killing it everybody dan you may I see I
throwing up the magnet shirt just lit
right there so you always gonna be big
some more surprises next week as we get
closer to pack house some more fine some
are some big guests coming up more big
guests for you guys we working on big
things we're cooking up but appreciate
the support
we appreciate the love everybody enjoy
your something we got playoffs we got
that Nana's get that red and gold a trip
let's go
you know I'm saying go go Titans if they
could put up like the Jets I'm being
easy get out they don't fit that
everybody snow everybody out